the thing to get people to realize is
that it's fun to be a corona it's fun to
pay your own bills and roll your own
vote and have the only key to the
apartment and I'm trying to women I'm
trying to man
we all have been infantilized into
thinking we have to cut deals that we
don't want the main the marriage the
corporation the union the party whatever
it is and people people sell themselves
terribly short and I don't know whether
this has always gone on or whether it's
always gone on a little but is now
getting worse but it is a it is a
wonderful thing to take charge of your
life your finances your spiritual
destiny your sexuality your your
artistic vision everything and we should
not cut deals you know one of the things
I learned that Berkeley as a radical
that I've never been able to export very
far and all the talking is being done is
people have become entirely too polite
you know at Berkeley in the old days we
used to we used it always at the tip of
our tongue day and night was the word
[ __ ] and you were to scream it at
the least hint of such material coming
you and and you were too in it didn't
matter cafeteria
restaurant and classroom when [ __ ]
raised its head you were to take aim and
fire instantly it's what I've come to
identify as a great evil in the world
thanks to my 19 year old son who has
brought me to this new viewpoint it's
it's relativist relativism is [ __ ]
and what is relativism relativism is the
idea that you really shouldn't criticize
other people's ideas because all ideas
are sort of on an equal footing so you
know I follow molecular biology you
follow Bob the G somebody else is a
Kabbalists somebody else worships their
broker and you're supposed to not
criticize
[Music]